i am not preparing to leave uh right now
um i did receive an email from the
british embassy yesterday
uh suggesting that i should uh leave as
soon as possible with uh any commercial
flights otherwise they will not be
available after a while uh to fly out um
i'm married to ukraine national i've
been for six years
um it's not an option she can't we come
to england uh we live here
so it's not really an option for us
right now um that's the situation with
me i can't speak for other people um but
yeah that's that's what's going on i
think uh embassies and governments are
suggesting that their um you know their
their people leave
i've heard this from americans from
other british expats here um
so you really are prepared you really
are prepared to stay come what may
um i have no choice i have a family here
i have a life here my wife um you know i
did inquire for the british embassy my
wife has to get a visitors visa to apply
for that if the embassy is closed
there's no chance we're getting that um
you know i live here i've said all my
life here um
for the moment it's not an option for me
um
i think the news is a bit more hyped up
than it is it's something that we should
take seriously of course
um you know people uh you know people
are moving around and people are moving
out um
but
for me right now it's not an option to
move i'm here
what is the general feeling where you
are at the moment you talk about it
being hyped up but clearly 130 000
troops around the border is uh clear
evidence that something is potentially
about to happen is it not
something is up uh ministry exercises or
not i think not
um you know not to take things lightly
but um you know things i'd be taking
being taken very seriously
um you know the war's been going on
since 2014 here it's escalated with the
uh you know russian forces now it's not
just uh russian black separatists which
were the problem before uh it is a
serious threat things are being taken
seriously luckily for us we're in the
west of ukraine um where we're looking
at central ukraine to belarus and to
eastern ukraine um you know those are
the hot areas
uh i'm 40 minutes away from the polish
border so you know fortunate for us in
that sense but yeah there's a real worry
i think there's a big concern
um
but things things are not looking good
things are not looking good here right
now
is there a sense of panic or or deep
worry about what might happen
okay i'm getting a lot of calls from
relatives family um you know a family in
italy family in england
and everyone's a bit more worried um
here the panic
this is non-existent i would say i think
a slight concern um you know um you know
there is news there's media going on
that's you know saying this or that
but here in ukraine not much panic going
on i have to say
um
maybe we've heard it all before uh maybe
people are in denial but
the sentiment here is not really panic
at all
do you feel that might change though in
the coming days if there is some kind of
invasion
well as i know if there's an invasion
we're going to be the last to hear about
it uh we'll hear it hear about it after
it's happened um
of course uh people from central and
east ukraine will start moving up
for sure there'll be a mass exodus of
people moving up towards west ukraine um
the living region where i am uh will
probably be inundated with people with
people trying to flee to get to the
slovakian or the um polish border
clearly you are preparing to stay put
with your your immediate family there
but what about relatives back home are
they worried for you
um yeah i have relatives um in london um
in italy that are very concerned
um my sentiment is i don't know if it's
a bit blase or if it's a bit kind of
arrogant but it's uh i tell them don't
worry until you see me start starting to
worry i'm not worried uh right now um
i'm concerned that i'm not overly panic
panicking or you know going crazy about
certain things um
i don't know if that's good or bad but
that's just the way it is a lot of
people around me um you know my family
here uh we're just living day to day uh
what can i say
all right well thank you for joining us
uh tonight thomas jones in ukraine there
thanks a lot thank you very much good
night